IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
EARLIER IN THE SHOW WE SHOWED
YOU THIS SEXY NEW BAT MOBILE.
BUT NEWS ALSO BROKE THAT
CHANNING TATUM WILL BE PLAYING
GAMBIT IN THE NEW X-MEN MOVIE.
WE SEEM TO DECIDEDLY
GENDER-MIXED ON THAT BEING OKAY.
IT LOOKS LIKE COMIC BOOKS ARE
GETTING STEAMY.
NO TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
IS #NAUGHTYCOMICBOOKS.
SHUT UP. YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT IS YET.
I JUST GET MAD AT THE
AUDIENCE.
SHUT UP!
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW.
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, AIDS.
ALRIGHT.
EXAMPLES WOULD BE "SUPERMAN ON
MAN," OR "X-MEN IN TIGHTS," OR
"300, 1 CUP."
>> SPARTA!
>> Chris: I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS
ON THE CLOCK, AND GO.
>> JUST ASSLEAGUE.
>> YES, POINTS.
>> THE GREEN THROBBIN'
>> YES.
>> THE FANTASTIC FOURPLAY.
>> RIBBED FOR HER-CULES PLEASURE
>> YES, POINTS.
>> THE APOLOGIZING FLASH.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: SO SORRY, THIS NEVER
HAPPENED.
SO SORRY.
>> SCAT WOMAN.
SORRY, SORRY.
>> SOMEBODY'S FILLED UP THE CAT
BOX AGAIN.
>> I'M SORRY, I JUST DID THAT.
POINTS.
Chris: MIKE.
>> DR. [BEEP]BLOCK-TOPUS.
Chris: OH, TOTALLY DO THAT.
POINTS. AL/
>> BATMAN VERSUS THE DIDDLER.
Chris: THE CAN I WATCH MEN.
GIVE HER POINTS.
>> THOR FROM LATH NIGHT.
[LAUGHING]